our advice to those shielding is to take
some steps now to start coming back to a
more normal lifestyle
this has been a very difficult and
sometimes frightening period for people
who've been shielding and therefore to
give people time to prepare we're
setting out the advice in a stepped
approach so first from July the six
which is a time period from when other
lockdown measures have been eased so we
can ensure we're monitoring the
epidemiology continuously we're advising
that people who are shielding may want
to start meeting in groups of up to six
people outdoors including those outside
their household if you live alone or
you're a lone parent you can think of
forming a support bubble with another
household those in a support bubble can
then spend time in each other's homes
including overnight and then secondly
from August the first we will pause
shielding will still be advising people
to stay at home as much as possible and
to minimize contact with others outside
their household but from August the
first our advice would be that people
can go out to more places see more
people this might include going to the
shops for example or visiting a place of
worship if you do leave your home you
should continue to keep a safe distance
from other people at all times
regularly washing your hands for 20
seconds is still one of the most
effective ways that you can protect
yourself if you're unable to work from
home from August the 1st you can return
to work as long as the business is kovat
safe when this program started we used a
precautionary principle new evidence is
telling us that the risks for
individuals are often more clearly due
to a combination of factors in that
individual such as age ethnicity obesity
levels for example as well as the
medical conditions that they have the
chief medical officer has commissioned
work to ensure that should we need to
step up the shielding program again we
would have available a much more
individualized way for you and your
doctor to be able to understand your
risk and to receive more tailored advice
the new risk assessment research
methodology is being
published today by academic colleagues
led by Oxford University in the future
therefore those we advise to take action
may be a slightly different group to
those who shielded through this new
disease pink one group where this is
particularly relevant is for children as
evidence has evolved we've seen that
admission to hospital for all children
under 18 years old with kovat 19 is very
low indeed only 36 children in the UK
have been admitted to intensive care
shielding guidance to date has covered a
broad range of conditions and clinical
vulnerabilities we know that many
parents have been worried about how they
can protect their children and they
often carry a considerable burden
themselves now we have new guidance
developed by the Royal College of
pediatrics and child health and this
will help families understand who does
and does not need to shield now we have
more evidence we can be much more
specific about risk and it's very likely
that in the future a very few children
will need to shield the evidence the
children's clinical experts have brought
together strongly recommends that
children and young people who are cared
for just in primary care are very
unlikely to need to continue to shield
in the future there is a group of
children that exists who due to their
underlying conditions may need to
continue to shield but over the summer
parents can look forward to discussions
through routine paediatric appointments
and in the interim we will be talking
with your doctors and the Royal Colleges
to ensure everyone has the right
information so for now there is no need
for parents to speak to their doctor
immediately and we will sort that
information out in in due course
for anybody with underlying clinical
conditions whether adult or child
looking forward and after shielding
advice is paused we would still continue
to advise you to be careful
keep your overall social interactions
down as low as feels comfortable
initially whether at home or at work and
keep practicing good hand hygiene and
good respiratory hygiene